[Music]
in business mistakes news mean submitted
by ketchup or mustard ketchup ketchup
all the way I like mustard I feel like
it's like cafeteria lady a research
company has outlined the top reasons why
entrepreneurs and their startups fail
ooh please let me know Thomas I don't
make this mistake one of them was
spending too much of the money that they
make already I worked for a [ __ ]
startup once that one had a lot of
promise like it was like Groupon but for
medical practices like for dental and
stuff like that
and then they suddenly shut down and
went out of business without telling me
even though I was making sales and then
I called him up I was a [ __ ] happen he
goes oh we shut down I was like why is
like I don't know there's we just ran
out of money I don't know why I'm like
maybe it's cuz you guys [ __ ] went
shopping in the middle of the day and
came home with six [ __ ] bags you dumb
[ __ ]
yes it was a worse you could have told
me cuz I kept working for you guys after
you guys shut down their top sellers and
then I was telling them to email all the
clients and I was getting nothing back
so I called him I said what the [ __ ]
happened you I thought we shut down I'm
like why did you tell us he goes and
this fool was such a [ __ ] this is
like frat boys [ __ ] he's like well I was
only gonna tell them if the employees
cared enough to call her asked what was
wrong like take note improve
communication skills
it was terrible do you think you can do
better than me I'm like [ __ ] yes and I
was 21 at the time you're [ __ ] dumb I
if you you know who the [ __ ] you are he
could just got morning last thing and
then the first it was a tiny there's a
study from the venture fund named
Kenbridge associate Tom Berg and they
found that the proportion of startups
that fail is in the ballpark of 60% I'll
tell you why number one people they're
good people are gonna be people it's a
good reason man I just wanna [ __ ]
make an app and sell it for millions
like the Chinese people do money bro
what app would you make like rumbler I
don't agree were you meet up and fight
people
real we made that up yeah you should
Megan oh it is make it yeah would that
would actually be pretty popular cuz
that's what Chinese people do they make
[ __ ] shits on absolute one sells they
make millions millions off it like that
that's flappy bird [ __ ] the Vietnamese
guy oh yeah
seven million I think but he quit though
what did he quit or something he quit
cuz he can't stand that the popularity
you think I just want to make a game
like stop [ __ ] bitching man thank you
sir I wanted too much too much fame and
fortune oh man okay I sound like a
little bit here are three common
mistakes every aspiring entrepreneur
should be mindful oh please so number
one common mistake is skipping the
co-founder so a lot of entrepreneurs
they feel that they can just build their
company just by themselves but what
tends to happen is like now like one
person doesn't have all the talents that
you need or skills you know that you
need you have a business and so not only
that but then they also need it's really
important to have another perspective
come in and look at what you're working
on because a lot of the times these
people they get tunnel vision they can't
see the big picture that's why it's
really important a thousand percent
could very true because I don't know
anyone that is successful that doesn't
have a co-founder all of my friends that
run businesses or been in the game for a
while they either did it like with their
sibling or their significant other or
like their friend I think the biggest
thing out of that is you got to make
sure the person you find has your
co-founder or your partner has to be
smarter than you has to be
hahaha here's failure right here you
just gotta find people that can that can
compliment you in areas that you like
it's like a balance you know it's hard
for people who micromanage to like when
I ran the the agency it's like it was so
hard for me to trust other people
elaborate it should because I ran like
the from everything from the casting to
picking the girls to get signing with
the the clients to doing invoices to
doing contracts to doing insurance and I
did it all by myself and it was so
tiring oh you [ __ ] up you didn't hire
me I could have been it as a model JD
associates Jake and calories Jamie huh
what's Jay excuse me
oh no you know you know but yeah we're
just us two and a [ __ ] what it sold 4
million yup we probably would have sold
way more than your girls sold oh we
should do it but you're so busy amen I
had to make a movie I know that's why
didn't bother you're like all right our
calendar would sell so well oh dude and
I'll be way more naked than you that's
the boy
play like yeah like the thing when what
I learned from my friend is you're not
truly a business owner or running the
business unless you hit let other people
running for you obviously I don't know I
don't trust people can do it yeah I do
but I'm nuts the reason why it took so
long to actually do like YouTube stuff
to you like I don't know if I trust
people's anything because I let someone
edit the first time I did a video it was
it's hot garbage sometimes but now I
found some good editors so I see
I'm trying to find an editor yeah god
damn that wedding video oh okay
so the second mistake is missing a great
idea on paper and so I guess when they
liber8 is that a lot of these is this
idea they don't really have a market for
it and they don't think about that so
they'll come up with a business idea
where no one really wants it it's
extremely niche niche yes like we're
gonna [ __ ] create shoes that dry
themselves yeah no I really no one after
you for that trees for people who only
have six toes like for the people that
such a there's such a fine line for that
too because lower finger there's a lot
of things that we think that other
people don't want that we only think
about but a lot of people want it so
they're it's so interesting because like
there's somebody who says this
innovation is actually telling somebody
that they need something they didn't
know
yes sure for me I always feel like [ __ ]
like that you have to appeal to a
person's narcissism or their laziness
like social media appeals to narcissism
everyone swoosh it about themselves or
laziness I post my beanie and vegans
like to save people time like two things
I would have never known that I wanted a
duffel bag that had a shoe compartment
yeah I mean like there was a side
compartment then you put like two shoes
in it I always in my duffle bag you
haven't for basketball I have my gym
bags and they have one for your
basketball and they have one for your
shoes and it has a vent so if when your
shoes stink all the smoke goes out yeah
why was I not told this I feel like if
you want to invent something just just
be very hyper aware of like your
everyday routine we're like [ __ ] is
still frustrating like tangle the
earphones or whatever you like that I
just want to knock up somebody who has a
lot of money there we go that's a good
business plan want them to control me I
mean as long as I get to just do what I
want invention you like I don't think
about it's just the most simple
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] damnit like the [ __ ] every
time I go to the bathroom I see my poo
pourri bottle like [ __ ] genius
Oh essential oils question I asked Joe
i'ma ask you for the next 12 years of
your [ __ ] life do you have to marry
this large large hairy hairy 80 year old
man thinking he's gonna live till he's
92 yes you're that and you gotta have
sex with them four times a week and not
like regular sex like love sex yeah four
times the way but four times a week four
times a week and yeah because the prize
is huge it is 20 million million dollars
and it's all of his s dates and you
can't cheat on him that's the man I ask
you would I cheat and masturbate but you
can't physical cheap I can't like look
you have to understand I came from an
era of go-go dancers and moldos where
that's all they did
oh yeah and I honestly I tried to go on
dates with like rich I [ __ ] went on
dates with like an oil tycoon but I
can't do it I can't pretend to like
someone I've never been able to and
trust me I've tried five years of your
life look like I've been surrounded by
this I can't do it
I wasn't even given the opportunity Gina
and I was surrounded by offensive this
dude was former male model he's
beautiful
I don't know this is billion not million
an oil tycoon and he was beautiful but
dinner was so [ __ ] bore I couldn't do
it I can't be a loser disgusts me I wish
I wish that I was a hoe that would [ __ ]
for money dude I was like oh my god
that's so interesting days and I'm just
like I can't do it oh my god all you
needed was three to seal the deal I got
a question just get pregnant hmm are
they nice old man here's me nice nah
David is this a little bit imaginary
this Oh for you the old lady is super
nice like she treats you really what
yeah I didn't show I do passionate sex
like look her in the eye but she's nice
watch and fall in love and share and mom
she's nice you know how hard it is to
find nice people in this world the new
baby he's he's 45 oh that's easy that's
not that bad I'll thinking like 6070
okay I have self-respect I'll never do
it for the money
but does she suck good good yes she take
our adventures and that's all you could
keep the lights off too she could talk
to me about the Great Depression the
third mistake that entrepreneurs make is
they scale up too quickly and then they
want to bring out a warehouse and it's
funny in this article cuz I thought
about Dickie they were like yeah you
know you don't need an a huge office in
downtown LA he you can just you said
that yeah like you can just attack me
next time [ __ ] what the [ __ ] yeah and
then they're just like you know you can
also work out of humble office like this
one that's what happened to nasty girl
yeah and they scaled it super scaled up
way too quick couldn't [ __ ] pay for
at all and now they went bankrupt I
think but I think everyone has to go
through this to learn because what they
don't tell you is the entrepreneurs that
go through all of this it's like a it's
like a cycle it's like the cycle of life
right it's like a relationship stage
everyone has to go through these stages
in a relationship all your coming yeah
so every person that starts opening up a
business and all that they all have
dreams of scaling big they all have
dreams of doing that and then they have
to they have to experience it and fail
in order to know okay and
my lesson now I gotta keep going what I
learned was when I was running that
business there was a lot of things I
didn't know and there was a lot of
things that I didn't [ __ ] know I
didn't know like insurance and [ __ ]
umbrella like a ten million dollar
umbrella [ __ ] focus it was crazy
yeah on that article they have this
little what does that say that says top
20 reasons startups fail so here are the
top 20 reasons where do the top three
the top three the first one is at 42% no
market need that's that's pretty huge
actually
number two ran out of cash 29% and then
number three not the right team 23% your
team is but also I know that because I'm
gonna be a lifetime entrepreneur it's
something where it like failures also
depending on how you see it too
because some people they build a
business to sell it's like those Chinese
ABS oh yeah are like maker studio they
sold it off to Disney or like whatever I
don't know if that was their main
attention but a lot of companies they
build companies so they could get it
swallowed up by a bigger company this is
true you know what's so upsetting about
you you could have married that
billionaire man and I'm you're still
thinking about that [ __ ] I could have
benefited from just being your friend
you are so selfish I wish I could be in
the Ferrari that you own for all you
know should we're not gonna be here with
us right now I know I [ __ ] that [ __ ]
they'll [ __ ] that car yeah I got hit my
two big rings I'm done I'm done with
that car I'm trying to sparking is still
useful
yeah hunt you are you working the red
spot something it's I parked on they do
just [ __ ] ran into my [ __ ] truck
and so yeah and there's a dead and they
scraped and I just kind of sat in the
car like you're in the car in the car I
was like boom and I turn around I might
I get out the car I [ __ ] you not I'll
show you guys a picture later the guy
comes out he's blind in one of his eyes
oh my god when he's driving driving a
semi illegal and his lies and his
driving license said he had 20/20 vision
this is interesting huh only me huh
20/20 vision like one white eye you
think this is my good one yeah oh yeah
he had the light the blue eye yeah this
is my good one yeah he looked like cable
yo cable looks sick the new one oh it's
[ __ ] dope he's one of my favorites
that was three Marvel heroes hey guys
would you think of that video I know you
loved it so make sure to hit that like
button to watch more videos check it out
up here
[Music]
[Music]